everyone this is kevin from the chest
website.com and today we are continuing
our coverage of the 2016 candidates
tournament we are in round 2 for those
just joining the coverage very important
try to make going on the winner of this
tournament plays Magnus Carlsen in
November for the world championship so
our opponents today why it's gonna be
played by the Russian Grandmaster Sergei
kind of hakkon his opponent playing the
black pieces is Nakamura from the United
States player that's probably playing
better chess than anyone else in the
world besides Magnus Carlsen
he's just been winning tournaments left
and right definitely my pick to win the
tournament also the player that just
cheering for because I think he would do
the United States proud I think him and
Magnus Carlsen facing off in a long
championship in November would be really
exciting for the chest community - very
aggressive players always going for the
win in any position so I think that'd be
really cool but we'll go ahead and get
to it
Sergei Academy I can definitely a strong
player and looking especially with the
white pieces to come out on top in round
2 so he get started with pawn to d4
Knight f6 pawn to c4 Ponte six at night
to f3 and then Nakamura kind of has an
option to do with the BOGO Indian
offense with a bishop here - before
instead he did opts for the Queen's any
defence with pawns who a b6 he to raise
to bring his bishop to either b7 or a
six white continues with pawn to g3
getting ready to bring his own bishop
here to g2 being kado try to
counter-attack control these light
squares in the center of the board
Nakamura plays Bishop to e6 that's kind
of the new normal back in the day you
would always see Big Bear to be 7 but
Bishop 286 is a lot more common now
starting to attack this pawn here on c4
now there's a lot of ways that white can
try to hold down this material here on
c4
you always have Knight - d -
unfortunately this kind of blocks this
Queen here on d1 from protecting this
pawn here on d4 you have Queen here - a4
which holds down the forward on c4 but
also stops holding down this material on
d4 same kind of goes with Queen here to
see - or b3 as well which is why white
usually continues
pawn to b3 what this does though is it
kind of weakens the dark square so
bishops gonna always come down here to
b4 which was what we see in the game
from Nakamura the knight can't come here
to see threes is what a lot of times
we'll see because the pawn on b2 is no
longer protecting that that's clearly
gonna be a mistake
but Knight here it's a d2 also is just
pretty uncomfortable for white we see
Bishop here to c3 and then the Knights
gonna or the rooks gonna have to come
here to be one huh and then all of a
sudden bishop here to b7 Bishop down
here to e4 just puts a lot of pressure
on white all of a sudden black is all up
in Y its grill over here and that's just
not something the white wants to do
white wants to be pretty aggressive
early on to the game having his opponent
just run amok with the double bishop
pair is not something the white wants to
do so in this particular spot you're
almost always going to be seeing bishop
here to d2 and black in this side if he
wants to go and get the bishops off the
board he can more common those what
knock more play and that's Bishop back
here to e7 now Bishop to g2 Sergei I
decides to go ahead and fee and kido his
bishop on the King side now pawn to d5
just trying to break up to turn the
board a little bit what do you see the
pawns come off the board castle on the
Kings side and then nakamora also
castles on the Kings side now Knight
here to c3 plus I've kind of looked on
board we do have a semi-open square on
the C file so white is eventually gonna
bring one of his ribs over here to see
one to control the semi open file on the
office decide the board Nakamura has a
semi open file on the e-file so he
eventually is gonna bring his rook here
to e8 as well but Knight to c3 just
simple development move and adding more
pressure on this square here on d5
now Knight here to d7 Nakamura wants to
make sure that he can push forward with
his palm whenever he wants to pawn here
to c5 and so Knight here to c6 that the
more common development move kind of
stops that push so that's go and play
knight here to d7 first and then Queen
here to see to rook over here to e8 e so
we talked about rook here to d1 he had a
few options you could have played rook
here to e1 if you wanted to so we could
push forward that's fine I couldn't even
brightest rook over here to d1
potentially decides wants to go ahead
and play
here to see one so for now decided to go
and play rook here - excuse me rook here
to d1 from f1 and now Knight back here
to f8 just right now Nakamura doesn't
have a lot of great options it was just
over time just trying to find a better
position for his Knight so he can look
sent and says okay night here on c6 is
going to be a better position for me at
night here to e5 Bishop here to a b7
trying to hold down this material right
here on on d5 but you can tell the kind
of the difference white his light-square
bishop ranjeet's who is attacking naka
more on the other side of his bishop
here on b7 is more defending bishop back
here to see - are c1 at night here to e6
attacking this pawn right here
bishop here - b2 and then bishop down
here to d6 now it was a little bit
different right here the knight can't
just come and take right now the roofs
just going to take right back but all of
a sudden the bishop kind of changes
things up
now if the knight were to take doesn't
matter if the rook takes then the bishop
could just take right here on e5 so why
it's kind of forced to play pawn to e3
which is not bad solidifies the pawn
chain right now also protects this pawn
here on d4 we're now see nakamura play
pawn to a6 kind of looking at what
surrogate kin - you know as dark square
bishop is kind of locked in this night
here at E 5 doesn't really have any
great squares to go to it has a nice
little outpost here the light square
bishop here on g2 absolutely is not
going anywhere he's just kind of holding
down the fort right here both the rooks
you know they're not gonna move too much
and the Queen doesn't have too much
going on this night right here on c3
it's probably the only piece that can
move somewhere and sanaka moistures
trying to limit his opponent's moves and
this is something that you should always
be looking for in your own game is
what's my opponent doing what's he
trying to do and then how can i limit
some of that success so you know if we
look at White's one of his options was
Knight here to b5 probably not gonna be
going anywhere else productive and so
pawn here to a6 although it seems like a
pretty innocent move it does a lot by
protecting and solidifying this square
here on a b5 so
Sergei kind of looked at this and said
okay my Knights not
anywhere so I do kind of need to move I
don't really have any other good option
so he decided to go and play night here
to e2 getting ready to bring it over to
the Kings side he sees much more value
with his knights over there now pawn
here it's a c5 starting to break open
this side of the board after we see an
exchange on board Knight here to c5 I'm
curious if Nakamura should have gone
with something a little bit different
the reason I say this is this pawn here
on d5 is now an isolated pawn which just
means there's no pawns on either side of
it and he's gonna be forced to kind of
defend this central square right here
where Sergei can just put all of his
pieces and just start to really apply a
lot of pressure to this pawn on d5 just
something I usually don't like to do in
my own games it's put a lot of just my
defence out here so you could have just
you know kept his C pawn you know added
a little bit of defense with this poncy
but right now does have a central square
here on d5 with no protection from pawn
so going to be very very important
square for the rest of the match now
Knight back here to a d3 since that pawn
here on d4 is no longer protecting the
knight here the other night is now kind
of forced to move not come more decides
it does not want to exchange and said
decides to play Knight here to e4 which
is nice little outpost the pawn here on
d5 does provide a lot about you because
it's a central square so knight here to
e4 also kind of blocks off this Bishop
on g2 from kind of protecting it what's
interesting is we kind of go back a
little bit you know on this position you
know Black has a fairly active position
on the board and when we come back just
a few moves and we see you know what
could white have done in this position
right here he decides to go ahead and
take and and give Nakamura that isolated
pawn but he had a pretty interesting
move and I'm not sure if he even saw it
because it is pretty crazy to come up
with but he had Knight here to c4 which
which looks pretty interesting but if
you if you kind of dig a little deeper
here this pawn right here is actually
protecting this Bishop back here on b7
if the pawn takes here on c4 then all of
a sudden the bishop takes here on b7 the
rook can come here to b8 that's fine
Bishop on a6 the pawn could take that's
fine pawn takes here on
be three all of a sudden this rook is
kind of opened up to kind of do whatever
he wants to why it's gonna be up in
material on board if that pond does not
take that night this is also gonna be
completely fine really starts to put a
lot of pressure both on this pawn here
on b6 this Bishop here on d6 so while
white did not play this not even sure if
he saw this move I do think that move
would have been pretty interesting on
board but we come back to this position
after the night here on e4 and then rook
over here to see one move that we talked
about earlier bringing the real company
to c1 controlling this file which has
gone from a semi-open file to a fully
open file so Nakamura decides to bring
his rook over here to see it you never
want your opponent's to just dominate
open files it kind of just keeps you in
a weird spot where they can get into
your house very easily eventually you
know rook here to c7 could be very bad
so we're going here to see I'm just
trying to hold down the line right here
Queen's gonna come back here to b1 make
sure he's not in the line of fire
Queen area to e7 a [ __ ] appear to d4
attacking this this pawn here on b6 we
do see exchange on board and then after
the exchange pawn here to b5 wants to
make sure that this bishop is not
attacking it but bishop round d4 is
actually a pretty good square it's an
outpost here with the protection here on
e3 it's controlling a lot of the stern
of the board so all in all I would say
white has a slight advantage both sides
have pretty active positions I do think
white is a little bit more aggressive
Nakamura is kind of in a spot where his
light-square bishop is still just kind
of hold on defensively to protection
this Knight is nicely placed a white
does have control of this open file
right here and this night right here on
f6 is not doing a whole heck of a lot
now pawn to a B for just kind of
stopping the push from nock more on the
Queen side not here to d7 just trying to
get into a better position here wasn't
doing too much here on f6 pawn here to
a3 just solidifying both sides kind of
have their pawns over here so that's
fairly normal a knight in here to half
ages so just kind of dancing around not
any other great squares for Nakamura to
go to which kind of is is probably
frustrating for him he likes to be
pretty aggressive
have lots of open lines that he can
play but how many variations that he can
get into so he's just kind of forced to
be moving his night a little bit so
night to f8 Bishop back here to a one a
nine here to e6 Queen here to a two
threatening this square here on d5 it
all kind of comes back to this one very
very important square here on a d5
Bishop back here to c7 night here to d4
Bishop here to a b6 attacking the knight
here and then h4 so starting to put a
little pressure on the the King side and
the next move is pretty startling I'm
not gonna lie I think everyone that the
kind of watch this game was was shocked
to see it I'm not sure if Nakamura just
decided that he was tired of just kind
of a lame-o position and wanted just
some fireworks but that's we did we got
fireworks he plays Knight takes here on
g3 sacrificing a night for a pawn
looking for compensation clearly after
the pawn takes I play Knight takes here
on a d4 after the bishop takes the
bishop takes here on the for pawn takes
now Queen to e3 check Queen to f2 night
excuse me Queen takes here on a d3 and I
really think you know afterwards he said
that the Sergey he kind of thought one
move deeper now I think there was the
next move that Nakamura didn't see he
didn't say what he was expecting my
guest as he thought maybe Queen here to
f2 potentially was expecting Queen here
to eight or King here to h2 both of
those I think are extremely good for
black he has a very very active position
on board he could have come away with
this you know up upon things are looking
really good for him unfortunately
Nakamura did not think quite as far
ahead as certainly a Kennedy I can did
and he missed this move right here rook
to c7 is a complete dagger there's
there's no way to overcome this he's
threatening both the Queen here on f7
which is check and not a lot of moves
he's also threatening just taking Anna
Bishop right here which would puts
Nakamura down an entire piece
you know pawn to f5 you got to stop the
checkmate but you can't stop the the
bishop falling here on b7 you know pawn
here it's age six sure
but now the bishops gonna gobble up more
my tail right here Bishop takes here on
d5 King here it's h7 Bishop down here to
g2 we should the rook down here to eat
to kind of a last-ditch effort and then
Bishop here to f1 say hey if you're
gonna move your Brooke I'm going to take
your queen and in this position Nakamura
had to resign Sergei Kathy Hawken
takes round two with a strong strong
performance really really well-prepared
put a lot of pressure on his opponents
knew what his opponent like to do and
put him in a tough spot where Nakamura
really couldn't get anything going the
entire match was just kind of playing
the Queen's Indian defense very
defensively and at the very end try to
make something happen but unfortunately
he just didn't calculate all the way
through and unfortunately fell in round
two so we've got 12 matches to make up
for hopefully he has a better showing
the rest of the way
but tough start for him so he'll be
coming back tomorrow definitely looking
for a win but exciting round two we've
had some some great matches so far
hopefully you guys are enjoying this
tournament one of the longer tournaments
that we have but we have the best
players in the world playing so excited
to see this but everyone thanks for
watching and I'll see you guys in the
next video